this video is sponsored by bookwalker
domestic girlfriend as we know i have a
love-hate relationship with domestic
girlfriend
i love domestic girlfriends and
i hate the fact that i love it so much
i'm sure this is the one series you're
all tired of me talking about
i've made three videos about it i've
reviewed it i've described the plot
while eating a [ __ ] ghost pepper and
i've had a mental breakdown over it but
since the manga ended
i thought that was it i thought my
journey with domestic girlfriend had
actually come to an end and i could
finally put this series to bed
and move on with my life and then i was
asked if i wanted to meet the author
hello everyone welcome to my very first
interview and today we have a very
special guest with me
uh today we have sasuke sensei who wrote
a
domestic girlfriend thank you very much
for joining me today sasuke
my first question is uh about your
um start in manga what made you decide
to pursue manga as a career
i know
foreign
so how did you get your start as a manga
artist
[Music]
[Music]
did writing good ending help you learn
anything to write domestic girlfriends
[Music]
[Music]
so unlike good ending domestic
girlfriend actually got an
anime adaptation um were you surprised
at all what was your reaction to that
so um a lot of
very like i call it spicy developments
happen in domestic girlfriend
very often and very fast it kind of
reminded me of like some
tv drama like some big tv drama was this
intentional what inspired
you to write the series in this way
[Music]
[Music]
one thing that really stood out to me
about domestic girlfriend was natsu's
development as a character
especially about his character arc as a
writer did you put any experience of
your own
as a writer into his story so
so hearing that it makes me wonder uh
did
you do something similar with hino and
rui like really becoming a chef
and uh hina's arc as well uh
[Music]
so
okay because with most romance manga i
read
the series ends when the main characters
get together
but in domestic nakanoja it like goes
further beyond that
was it challenging to keep the series
interesting even after
natsu and ruri uh got together ah so
this
you mentioned earlier about being
inspired by
what the viewer or what the reader said
of how they reacted to your manga
did that affect the mystic mechanism at
all as you were writing it
[Music]
we already know the ending of the manga
but i have to
i have to ask hina or ruiz
between your children
but uh yeah how did you decide the
ending of the manga yourself
um very curious
[Music]
did you want to end it on a bang because
as
as a reader it was very a lot of things
happening in a very short time
aside from natsu hino and rui were there
any other characters you were
particularly fond of
i know
i'm curious if you put a lot of your
experiences into your characters was
there
any side characters that you put a lot
of your other
experiences into as well
as
was there anything you regret about the
series or you want to
want to do differently
[Music]
i just wanted a quick question about uh
the more like
i say adult themes most romance manga
reader
you know kids said in high school but
this one definitely had more adult
relationships and everything like that
did you want to convey a more at our
relationship and domestic girlfriend and
what inspired that
um
how did you decide that it would be hina
that would be end up with natsuo and
not worry that's what i want to know as
a fan
of
[Music]
was there an overall message you wanted
to convey to your readers
in the messenger i know
[Music]
um
now that you finally finished domestic
girlfriend uh
what's next are you taking a break or do
you have any other series in mind that
you want to pursue
[Music]
thank you very much for coming here
today and taking time off your schedule
and as as a fan thank you very much for
writing domestic girlfriends
i very much enjoyed it thank you very
much
and yeah that was the entire interview i
want to give a quick thanks to gadansha
for making the interview possible and of
course
sasuke sensei for taking time out for
schedule and
giving me this amazing [ __ ]
present i wasn't expecting it and i
think this is the first time i ever
fanboy squealed in my life and i regret
nothing
because after today and everything that
happened all i can say is
guys if you shitpost hard enough maybe
you too
can make your dreams come true
before we go guys if you didn't know you
can read all of the domestic girlfriend
manga right now
on bookwalker until february 15th
pacific time the domestic girlfriend
bundle set volume 1 to 27
is 30 off and the final volume 28 will
be released on february the 9th so you
can pre-order it
now if you buy the final volume by
february the 15th you can even get a
special bonus illustration or if you
just need to catch up
buying any volume will get you 15
coinback to buy
more and don't forget you can use coupon
code giggup for five dollars off
check the link in the description for
more details again thank you to book
walker and kadantra comics for this
opportunity i'd love to do more
interviews like this
so if you'd like to support the official
release check the link in the
description for more details
anyway that's it from me i've been geek
and i'll see you
all next time